WATCH.
>> 1:29 A.M., SENATOR McCAIN
REENTERS THE CHAMBER.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL STANDS AT THE FRONT OF
THE ROOM LIKE HE HAD MOST OF THE
NIGHT.
THE GRIN ON HIS FACE, THOUGH,
QUICKLY DISAPPEARS.
>> MR. PETERS.
>> NO.
>> SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS
APPEARS TO NUDGE SENATOR GENE
S
SHAHEEN AS IF TO SAY, WATCH
THIS.
McCAIN WAVES HIS HAND TO GET THE
ATTENTION OF THE SENATE CLERK,
PAUSES FOR JUST A MOMENT, AND
GIVES A DRAMATIC THUMBS DOWN.
>> AUDIBLE GASP ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AND THEN COMMOTION.
SOME DEMOCRATS CAN'T CONTAIN
THEIR EXCITEMENT.
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN LEANS
IN TO GET A BETTER LOOK AND
BREAKS INTO APPLAUSE.
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN, A
SINGLE ASSERTIVE CLAP.
SENATOR SHERROD BROWN SLAMS HIS
HAND ON THE DESK IN AFFIRMATION
WHILE SOME REPUBLICANS, LIKE
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO STARE IN
DISBELIEF.
SENATOR BILL CASSIDY DROPS HIS
HEAD.
CHUCK SCHUMER WAVES HIS ARMS,
APPARENTLY TRYING TO QUIET THEM
AS SENATOR JOHN McCAIN TURNS
AROUND AND WALKS BACK TO